thing passionate the only one gotta get
a rework yeah yes
this is your tank 2.0
that's what you can expect from next
season
but uh jokes aside this is the moment
we've all been waiting for please give a
warm welcome to overwatch elite hero
designer jeff goofman jeff how are you
doing hey how you guys doing thanks
we're doing great do you like our rework
yeah
yeah big
it really doesn't it's still warm though
it's still warm you wouldn't like it
i'm just in my room i'm jealous
let's start with a really easy question
for you when's the release date no i'm
i'm just i'm just kidding i had to shoot
my shot though
but seriously
what can you tell us
about how the game is coming along so
far
now it's come along great i mean we're
doing
just constant play tests all the time
and finding new things we want to try
and a lot of things that aren't working
a lot of things that are working sort of
surprising us so
um i think we're sort of
in this world now where we're still sort
of experimenting with a lot of big
things like
you know just as an experiment we're
going to try doomfist as a tank and
stuff like that i don't know if that'll
work it probably won't work but you know
yeah exactly
all right all right jeff uh why don't we
let's let's just give the people what
they want i think the first thing that
we'll be looking at is the new sombra
rework um anything you want to say to
you know set this up
yeah so i mean a lot of this is uh i you
know we've talked about this a little
bit before but um we have this sort of
goal we're going for right now to try to
sort of
reduce crowd control effects uh
throughout the game um and a lot the way
we're sort of targeting that is nice um
kind of leaving it on
tanks it's kind of like a big thing that
they get to do and it's like their big
role um among other things we could do
of course but that so it really comes
down to is we're looking at all the
non-tanks and figuring out you know what
kind of crowd control is really
necessary
what do we think we can get away with um
what feels kind of fair and what feels
kind of unfair i know that's a little uh
little hand baby but i thought everyone
has their own opinion on that i'm sure
but um so for right now for example ana
still has her sleep dart we kind of feel
like that's pretty fair and i know maybe
we'll find out that people people don't
like that i don't know i think i think
most people think it's pretty cool but
um but it's part of these changes
but the spreading stage of sombra is
definitely you know
a big target because it's like she
hasn't she's all about crowd control in
some sense um so
that's where a lot of the rear work
comes from so the first thing is really
just like how to reduce her
sort of uh disabling effects while still
keeping it really strong so i think
that's a decent lead and i think all
kind of
so i like the sound of that uh let's
just dive straight in and take a look at
the sombra or rework yes please
[Music]
for sombra's rework we have some really
important changes that can dramatically
affect the way she's played
overall we are reducing her cc abilities
in line with larger changes to overwatch
2 and giving her more potential damage
let's start with changes to her hack
ability
first we significantly reduce the
cooldown secondly her hack now lasts
eight seconds but now has two components
to it
the first component of the ability works
exactly like it does in overwatch one
disabling abilities
however that effect now has been reduced
to one second
the second component of hack is a brand
new effect that reveals hack targets to
sombra and her team through walls and it
lasts the entire duration of the hack
in addition to that her passive has
gained the ability to do 50 more damage
to hacked targets
for her ultimate ability we tweaked it
so it no longer removes all shields but
instead it now just deals damage to
enemies equal to 40 of their current
health combined with her new passive
effect this gives her even more
finishing potential
lastly
an update that really leans into her
character is that you can now hack
while being in stealth mode you are
briefly revealed when hacking but it no
longer removes stealth completely
see you later
[Music]
wow
i'm a main tank player you know straight
off the bat everyone knows this uh that
looks so fun though emps and hacks is a
big part of my overwatch life
now hopefully not as much anymore so i
mean you mentioned it going into the
video of course you've been taking an
approach talking about these different
crowd control effects whether it's maze
freeze ability and in this case sombra's
hack ability um what was your thinking
uh when it came to hacks from sombra how
did you approach this ability and what
did you decide to change it
yeah so it was pretty tricky because uh
you know she's so
tied to this crowd control effect so we
wanted to but we didn't want to take the
hack away from her because she's a
hacker that doesn't make any sense so we
want to still be coordinating she plays
um so we started looking at other
effects and what could we do um that is
impactful but isn't quite as as brutal
as just locking somebody out of their
abilities for so long uh we actually
tried a version for a while which you
just couldn't disable abilities at all
um but there are some cool moments where
you get to sort of uh you know counter
like a firearm that you see in the video
or something if you just if you're there
at the right time or you're waiting for
it the right time so we ended up keeping
it in for just a short period of time
much shorter than usual just it's almost
more of an interrupt than actually you
know um setting somebody up for a long a
long duration thing yeah um but we let
the hack last longer and then most
importantly she gets to do a ton more
damage when she against hack targets so
it's really this play when you're
playing against her where
you know she can hack while she's
stealth so uh you know your backline
starts to get hacked it's almost like a
like a
like a flag drop like i'm about to come
at this person it's like a warning to
everybody that you know and it's it's
almost like a disadvantage of her in a
way exactly
um where you know she has to essentially
call her targets before she gets to do
real big damage to them so um but on the
flip side she gets to do way more damage
yeah i'm a big fan of that i do think
there's a really good place for sombra
in overwatch and i like these changes as
well the ability to mark targets
essentially and then go after them i i
think it's a really interesting change
yeah i mean i think am i the only one
that's super excited for the uh to just
i just wanna i'm always on the receiving
end i don't play sombra so i'm i'm like
obviously less excited for what i said
with this
yeah maybe we can we can be the sombra
player oh yeah
well i mean i mean yeah jeff you talked
a little bit you talked actually a lot
about the new rework and everything but
i want you to you know i want to ask you
a little bit deeper what direction uh
are you trying to go with sombra just as
a hero
right
so i mean she
i've always liked that she's sort of
this
a little more of a setup hero like
obviously she still requires a decent
amount of aim skill but she's not you
know the widow or or anything of the
group so but so i like that she's got
this hybrid sort of
very situational uh awareness and timing
game going on but also you know
obviously being
decent aiming helps a lot with her um so
i wanted to keep a lot of that intact
and so i think a lot of what we see here
is sort of deepening that in a way
because
um you know when we've been play testing
it for example we've done there's a lot
of like kind of mind gaming things you
can do because the hack cooldown is
really low now
so like i said before when you hack
somebody you're kind of calling him out
like i'm about to open this guy do much
damage but like you could hack somebody
and then you're still stealth to run to
completely different area hack somebody
else and your whole team like rotated to
help that person but then you have
somebody else and go after them instead
and like it's so sombra to be able to
just like mess with people like that
it's so great
it's super fun plus the emp that's so
much more powerful
right right and i did want to talk to
that because the the element of the hack
that makes it powerful now is the extra
damage increase and a support player
who's been hacked also a lot in my life
the the fear of that damage is going to
go up even higher especially with that
emp is that a big like tuning moment of
like how much damage can this sombra
really put out because she's going more
to as you said uh dps than a crowd
control hero um and in this sort of
rework yeah definitely um it's it's
actually really interesting to play with
um because it doesn't remove shields
anymore like it used to so actually it
does less damage to zarya and zenyatta
um any hero that has a ton of extra
shields um because it doesn't strip them
anymore
actually
um so you know it but against everybody
else it's just way better especially
against tanks it's forty percent of
their current health so um it's
different than uh sigma's outline where
it's it's their max health so it can't
actually kill anybody but you know the
earlier you do when the fight has a big
setup move it does so much more damage
and weakens everybody um it's this great
sort of alley-oop you know obviously
into a graph or something that's great
like well everything in new graph is
great so that doesn't really change but
yeah
well uh right jeff sombra isn't the only
hero getting a reworking award to uh of
course you will be working on
basically everything but uh here on our
watchman pre-show we are
also going to take a look at bastion's
rework because there is more to him than
just a a pretty robot with a hat
anything you want to say before we roll
the tape
um the tape probably shows pretty much
everything but i will say um it was
definitely a goal to
much like sombra i guess try to maintain
some of that
that general flavor of sort of being
able to sacrifice your mobility for
extra damage um but we did want to pull
back on a little bit because got to the
point where it was sort of like
impossible to play him as i completely
yeah
yourself so
that should be deleted we'll see
we'll see indeed well let's uh you know
let's dive straight in let's roll the
tape and see what you guys have done
with
bastion bastion is getting a big rework
for overwatch 2 and the team is really
excited about his changes look wise we
updated and modernized his appearance
with the use of sleeker more modern
materials we also gave him a hat to help
him stand out and to add an extra touch
of character
so going through bastion's abilities uh
well for starters he no longer has his
self-repair button at all it's just gone
instead he now has a brand new ability
that's bound to alternate fire this
ability fires a projectile that can
bounce off of walls and stick to players
and it does a ton of damage has a really
big radius it's super fun to fire his
reconfirm weapon has changed
significantly as well and now has no
spread at all but has reduced fire rate
to compensate this lets him poke at much
longer ranges and play a little more
like a pseudo sniper kind of like his
recon form theme is always kind of meant
to be
for his ultimate we completely change it
up
no longer has this tank mode he instead
goes into a new artillery mode
you then get to choose three points to
call down an artillery strike anywhere
on the map within the abilities timer
now finally something we think you'll
all be excited about while in sentry
form bastion can now move albeit at a
reduced movement speed we've also
changed the ability to have a cooldown
now this lets us keep it super strong
since you can't use it all the time
[Music]
oh okay
wow
all right those are certainly some
changes and i have a lot of questions
but i feel like i need some time to
process this uh you want to take over
reinforce yeah i mean i i have a lot of
questions i have a lot of questions i
have very good ones of course because
that was uh amazing uh reworking bastion
of course from more of a specialist you
know being in the now he has more
mobility as you mentioned uh what was
the problems you were trying to fix with
bastion and making these changes in the
rework
yeah so with bastian you know he's
was one of our earliest heroes and uh
the game was a lot different back then
of course and uh
you know
we tried to tune sort of this huge
disadvantage with just not being able to
move with just like how do we give him
enough firepower to make that worth it
and there i don't know if there's some
magic tuning point but i'm sure we
definitely tried a lot of numbers to
work there but it really comes down to
the fact that
like
being unable to move in a game like
overwatch you have heroes that have so
much mobility and so much burst damage
like it's kind of just unrealistic to
try to like tune that in such a way that
makes any sense
um so we first you know kind of went to
the drawing board on him again and it
was like let's look at the sort of
elephant in the room here and like does
he really need to be completely immobile
um to have this sort of effect so that's
sort of where we start experimenting
right away with like maybe you can move
somewhat
even just be able to move a little bit
yeah like
go behind covered stuff is a huge
difference um so he's at 50 move speed
right now i mean all these numbers you
know going on right now are subject to
change of course we're doing a lot of
testing and stuff yeah yeah but yeah
for sure
i love the look of it though it's just
this slow almost comedic
deadly choo choo train coming out
i hope it makes sounds before it rounds
the corners you know it's confident oh
no
i love it now i have some time to you
know recollect my thoughts i i do need
to know that how much damage does that
artillery actually do and even more
importantly can genji deflected
right right yeah it's a pretty
interesting ability because you know
it's
it's almost a little bit like doomfist
old where you get to create these you
know this targeting area to to to drop
well in this case uh artillery shells
but it worked kind of like doomfist for
targeting purposes
but you get to shoot three of them and
uh the actual projectile coming down
from above is
a projectile like any other so it can be
defense matrix it can be reflected it
can be you know all these things so
you can look up and block it with
reinhardt
it's possible for it to hit a flying
pharah if she's really unlucky like it's
just flying oh
my my mind is going wild with
possibilities right now like what can we
do with yes
a lot of things like if you flux them
and they're up in the air and then you
strike them when they're in the air or
just what or just grab them and just
grab they're always coming to the grab
yeah yeah everything just goes well with
the graph
answer to everything yeah it's like
black clothing like how that works
all right oh i have this might not be a
smart question but i really wanted to
ask this so my favorite questions thank
you for bastion rework was the sentry
mode i find that very cute as well and i
think i'm going to enjoy it how long can
you stay in that form is there a time
limit or can you just just roll around
or is it rolling forever
forever yeah drive forever
so it has a cool you want it which is
pretty different um i mean before i was
part of his sort of you know kit to be
able to transform wherever he wanted to
but it got to the point where he really
wanted to keep a lot of power in this
thing even though he can move we wanted
to be very very powerful and when you
see him come around the corner you'd be
really scared of it and you know maybe
have to back up or give him some space
or something um so in order to really
get that sort of power level we wanted
it we decided to put a cooldown on it
for now so you can't do it all the time
but up time on it's pretty high so uh
you definitely are gonna be able to do
it a lot but um it allows us to like
make the ability a lot more oh yeah that
way
also
it's like a cinderella pumpkin kind of
right
it's just a touch
[Laughter]
ultimate question real quick uh the
damage on the alt is cause i know people
are gonna wanna know this stuff for sure
some people anyway uh the impact the
actual shell coming down from the sky
actually does impact damage too much
like our fire rockets and junkrat bombs
and stuff like that uh the impact does
300 right now and the explosion also
does 300. so direct hit is 600 if you
happen to get hit by it directly oh wow
which is really nasty but it's pretty
unlikely to get hit directly um and then
it does you know a bunch of fall off
from the point of impact out too it's
it's it's full radius
he's gonna be the lucky one in the
middle of it
i have a problem dodging wrecking ball
minds i now have another thing that i
have to really avoid
here are three doomfist ultimates
[Laughter]
when you said you were changing doomfist
i didn't expect that i'd have to deal
with another another person like that so
i am interested though because you know
the first thing i thought of when i saw
it rolling around i was like they just
wanted to bring pirate ship back but
make it so he can do it himself he's his
own little pirate ship now just like
rolling around
i don't need a shield with me i can do
it all myself so
my question with that is like what is
the most interesting thing that you've
seen with this kit change because
there's a lot there's the mine there's
the rolling around in century we want
the artillery what's your favorite thing
oh man there's a lot to sort of uh
comment on here so it's
i really love the old i think it's super
fun
the fact you get three shots uh you get
a lot of kind of mind games with that
too because typically when you first
play you're probably just gonna like you
know carpet bomb in area bam bam bam
click them as fast as possible gives
people less reaction time but also what
you can do is drop them like right on
top of everybody and then drop one kind
of where you think they're about to go
and then hold the third one for a couple
beats and then drop it like you can just
really mess with people on how you're
dropping it because you get to sit there
for a little while i'm afraid oh my gosh
to mess with people i mean you have to
be a little weird because you're sitting
there much like junkrat is when he does
ultimately you're sitting there
vulnerable somewhere and hopefully no
one's killing you or you're protected or
something um so i've definitely got
caught sometimes just like being in some
silly place sitting there for too long
but that's pretty fun the mind games
returns
um i do have one one last question i
would like to ask anyway yeah um and i'm
pretty sure you know i've asked you this
several times i've had the chance to
speak with you but i can't remember the
answer this happened with the rework
have you actually tried
bastion being able to mount like orisa
and why did that not work
why the lord would anyone want that it's
amazing it's like jousting
did you try it out that sounds like an
arisa ability more than a basketball
game to me
just throw someone up there
so what i'm hearing from that answer
jeff is
it's not out of court
i fear for the sanity of our animators
to try to make that look decent in any
way possible
but yeah maybe
i appreciate it i appreciate it
let's not go there
but hey kudos to you for pushing it a
reinforcement i'm trying my best yeah
you're really great you really do i i
really appreciate it i also really
appreciate you taking the time here to
chat with uh jeff we can't wait to see
what else you and the team have in store
for us thank you so much for joining us
today sure no problem great to be here
thanks a lot